Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 98. Ausgabe dieser Gesprächsreihe.
Und ja, heute geht es um die Metaebene von allen Dingen, wir wollen uns heute über Philosophie unterhalten.
Und das mache ich mit meinem heutigen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Markus Schrenk, schönen guten Tag.
Ja, guten Abend.
Ja Herr Schrenk, Sie sind bei der Universität in Düsseldorf, ich will es korrekt sagen,
das ist die Heinrich-Heine-Universität Düsseldorf.
So ist es.
Und dort als Professor für theoretische Philosophie.
Gibt es auch praktische Philosophie?
Es gibt tatsächlich auch praktische Philosophie und man ist etwas erstaunt, wenn man diese zwei Begriffe hört.
Die theoretische Philosophie beschäftigt sich so mit den Fragen, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält beispielsweise.
Und die praktische Philosophie mit den ethischen und moralischen Fragen.
Wie sollen wir handeln, was ist eine moralisch gute Handlung beispielsweise.
Oder auch mit Politik, das ist die praktische Philosophie.
Also es ist eigentlich genauso wie bei den Physikern.
Da gibt es ja auch die Theoretiker und die Praktiker.
Ja, die gibt es.
Also die experimentellen, nennen die sich.
Diese Zweiteilung gibt es in der Tat, ja.
Ob das jetzt genau parallel ist, da müsste man noch mal drüber nachdenken.
Gibt es auch experimentelle Philosophie?
Aber es stimmt insofern schon, dass die theoretischen Physiker und Physikerinnen natürlich die Grundlagenforschung machen.
Sich auch anschauen, was die Welt im Innersten zusammenhält, auf eine andere Art.
Wie die Metaphysik beispielsweise, aber da ist eine Parallele.
Bei der Praxis weiß ich nicht so genau, ob ich da eine Parallele sehe.
Das Experimentieren und die Moralphilosophie.
Aber das ist eigentlich gar nicht so ein schlechter Vergleich.
Weil wenn man sich mit theoretischen Physikern unterhält, da geht es halt auch wirklich um die Metafragen.
Also was ist eigentlich das Weltall? Wo kommt es her? Etc.
Und letzten Endes sind es philosophische Fragen an der Stelle, die aufkommen,
weil man sie ja gar nicht mit einem Experiment, zumindest noch nicht, beweisen kann.
Die erst mal nur versuchen, Modelle zu schaffen.
Ist das in der Philosophie dann auch so, dass man das alles nicht beweisen kann?
Ja, es ist jedenfalls eine sehr interessante Frage, was ein philosophischer Beweis überhaupt ist
und wann man von gesichertem philosophischem Wissen sprechen würde.
Das ist eine eigene philosophische Frage, die man betrachten kann.
Oh.
Und die Physik, klar, die hat natürlich, die kommt an ihre Grenzen einerseits in der experimentellen Forschung,
weil man an bestimmte Energien noch nicht rankommt, das ist eine Grenze, die die Physik finden kann,
aber es gibt natürlich auch Fragen, die dann wirklich ins Philosophische abgleiten.
Also eine Physikerin wird zum Beispiel sehr viel mit Zahlen zu tun haben,
die muss sich sehr viele Formeln durchrechnen.
Und die Frage aber, was ist eine Zahl und wo existiert die denn eigentlich,
denn die kann man im Teilchenbeschleuniger nicht nachweisen,
wo ist die Zahl Fünf eigentlich, welches Dasein hat die denn eigentlich?
Zahlen gibt es ja wohl oder?
Aber wo?
In der konkreten Welt wohl nicht.
Der Zahl Fünf sind Sie sicher noch nicht begegnet.
Würde ich so nicht sagen.
Schon ist man in philosophischen Fragen.
Oder nehmen Sie ein anderes Beispiel.
Ich finde das Beispiel super, weil eigentlich ja die Fünf oder wie jede andere Zahl ist ja eigentlich das Ergebnis einer Abstraktion.
Weil es wird ja in dem Moment erst zählbar, wo man irgendwie Dinge überhaupt voneinander abgrenzen kann
und sagen kann, da ist was zu Ende, dort beginnt etwas neues, hier kann ich jetzt auch wirklich weiter zählen.
Und diese Abzählbarkeit des Universums ist ja glaube ich, oder überhaupt, sagen wir mal, unserer Welt,
ist ja vielleicht so auch eine der Primärleistungen des Menschen überhaupt.
So überhaupt die Umwelt zu erfassen.
Jetzt nicht, also auch Tiere tun das sozusagen, also ist ja nicht nur so, dass die…
Ja, rudimentär bestimmt.
… abstraktionsfrei sind, die können irgendwie Individuen unterscheiden und haben Beziehungen zu anderen Wesen.
Also die können definitiv zählen, ob sie es so viel benutzen, steht noch mal auf einer anderen Schwelle.
Aber das ist natürlich etwas, was schon ein Ausdruck ist.
Aber letzten Endes kann man ja nur abzählen, wenn man irgendwie auch eine Vorstellung davon hat, was etwas ist.
Und von daher ist es einfach pure Philosophie, würde ich sagen, fast.
Ja richtig.
Was für ein Einstieg.
Vielleicht noch zu Beginn würde mich erst mal natürlich interessieren, wie Ihr Weg in die Philosophie überhaupt so gelaufen ist.
Aber ich muss natürlich auch noch mal kurz sagen, was passiert ist,
Sie haben nämlich den Kommunikatorpreis 2022 vom Stifterverband bekommen.
Nicht Sie allein, sondern das gesamte Projekt mit dem schönen Namen „denXte“.
Und da stecken ja noch ein paar andere Leute dahinter, richtig?
Genau, denXte ist ein Team, Amrei Bahr und David Niemann sind von Anfang an mit dabei.
Die haben 2019 mit mir die Reihe ins Leben gerufen.
Christoph Sapp ist etwas später dazugekommen, aber fast unmittelbar danach.
Und die jüngsten Mitglieder sind David Löwenstein, Julia Frese und Berit Weiß.
Gut, auf denXte gehen wir gleich noch mal ein.
Jetzt muss ich aber noch mal rauskriegen, wie das bei Ihnen eigentlich so war.
Ich meine, Philosophie, in welchem Alter entscheidet man sich für das Thema oder kann man sich entscheiden?
Oder sollte man spätestens?
Spätestens mit fünf.
Ich weiß nicht, bei mir war es tatsächlich ziemlich früh.
Das hat bestimmt begonnen mit religionskritischen Fragen.
Also was weiß ich, vom Kommunionunterricht aufwärts habe ich mich mit Fragen danach beschäftigt,
ob es Gott gibt oder ob das alles so richtig ist, was mir im Religionsunterricht erzählt wird.
Und das war bestimmt so ein Anstoß, sich über die Welt Gedanken zu machen und auch über das, was vielleicht hinter der Welt steht.
Das Transzendente.
Und deswegen war das wirklich in meinem Falle ein sehr führen Interesse,
die Kinderfragen, die man hat, die haben bei mir einfach nicht aufgehört.
Die sind einfach geblieben, und deswegen war der Wunsch, Philosophie zu studieren, schon sehr früh da.
Ich hatte auch so einen philosophischen Moment, als mir irgendwie unsere Klassenlehrerin den Unterschied zwischen Menschen und Tieren dadurch klarmachen wollte,
dass sie meinte, ja die Menschen sind diejenigen, die ich zu sich sagen können.
Und ich weiß noch, wie ich innerem Furor zerbarst, weil ich mir dachte, woher will sie das denn wissen?
Woher will sie das wissen.
Aber da gibt es ja sehr sehr interessante Experimente, die zeigen, dass Tiere vielleicht nicht das Wort ich oder diesen Begriff benutzen,
aber einige Tiere können das ja, die können sich selbst im Spiegel identifizieren als das Individuum, was sie sind.
Also Delfine können das, glaube ich, verschiedene Affenarten, Schimpansen mindestens,
Bonobos wahrscheinlich, aber das ist jetzt keine, das müsste man nachlesen.
Ja, aber ich meine, man muss sich nur zehn Minuten mal einen Orang-Utan anschauen
und dann denkt man über so was gar nicht mehr nach.
Ja, ob der das kann, das müssten wir wirklich nachgucken, das können nicht alle Affen.
Also jedenfalls diese Selbsterkennung im Spiegel ist nicht allen Affenarten möglich, nicht allen gegeben.
Soviel weiß ich, aber welche das sind, die es können, das müsste man wirklich jetzt nachlesen.
Vögel können das auch, ich glaube, bei Elstern hat man es jetzt kürzlich nachgewiesen,
dass die auch ein Selbstbild von sich haben.
Das heißt, diese Einteilung Ihrer Lehrerin, Menschen sind diejenigen Tiere, die sich selbst identifizieren können, ist falsch.
Also zumindest würden dann noch Affen und Elstern zum Menschen zählen, wenn das richtig wäre.
Genau. Ich fand einfach nur die Behauptung etwas frech.
Naja, die Wikipedia ist sich sicher, dass Orang-Utans sich auch im Spiegel erkennen.
Ach wunderbar, dann gönnen wir es ihnen.
Ja, genau.
Ich hatte nie einen Zweifel daran.
Okay, also diese Selbstzweifel kommen auf, ist klar, ist glaube ich etwas, was jeder von sich kennt,
auf die ein oder auf die andere Art und Weise.
Die Frage ist nur, entscheidet man sich danach gleich für ein Philosophiestudium oder versucht man es irgendwie anders zu begegnen.
Mit welcher Erwartung haben Sie denn das Philosophiestudium begonnen?
Ja, da ist eine falsche Voraussetzung dahinter.
Ich habe mit Physik begonnen.
Ach guck an.
Ich habe dann gar nicht Philosophie zunächst studiert, sondern Physik,
weil mir die Berufsaussichten zu unsicher schienen, und zurecht.
Ja.
Aber ich habe dann doch später dann umgewählt, haben Physik zum Nebenfach gemacht,
Logik war ein zweites Nebenfach und habe dann nach dem zweiten Jahr, glaube ich, habe ich gewechselt zur Philosophie.
Und dann dort den Magisterabschluss gemacht.
Aber immerhin schon mal die Basics mitgenommen, das ist doch schon mal ganz gut.
Die Basics der Physik, die habe ich noch mitgenommen, ja.
Okay. Und wie führte dann der Weg nach Düsseldorf?
Ja, das ist ja bei Akademikern meistens eine längere Trajektorie.
Begonnen habe ich in Bonn mit dem Magisterstudium.
War in der Zeit als Visiting Student in Oxford und da hat es mir so gut gefallen,
dass ich mich dann auf den Dephil(?), das ist der Doktortitel, den man dort erwerben kann, beworben habe
und bin dann 2000 wieder nach Großbritannien zurückgekehrt und dann dort erst mal kleben geblieben.
Also nach fünf Jahren Promotion in Oxford hatte ich meine erste Stelle als Lecturer dort
und dann gibt es ganz verschiedene viele Standorte noch.
Ich war in Nottingham angestellt, dann auch mal kurz in Luxemburg,
in Köln ist eine lange und wichtige Station für mich gewesen, bis ich dann 14 den Ruf nach Düsseldorf bekommen habe.
Also die klassische Rundreise.
Ja genau.
Ja, aber hat ja auch was für sich, so lernt man die Welt kennen und dass die Dinge nicht überall genauso funktionieren.
Unterscheidet sich denn die Art und Weise des Umgangs mit der Philosophie in Deutschland und in Großbritannien?
Nein, also es ist so, es gab mal eine große Zweiteilung in der Philosophie.
Das nannte man, nennt man noch, analytische Philosophie und kontinentale Philosophie.
Und in beiden Begriffen merken Sie schon, da stimmt irgendwie was nicht,
wie kann man das analytische mit dem kontinentalen eigentlich vergleichen,
da hinkt doch irgendetwas.
Was man meinte, ist, dass die analytische Philosophie, die hat sich sehr stark an Logik und an Naturwissenschaft orientiert.
Ist sehr stark durch die Naturwissenschaften auch informiert und ihre Argumentationsweisen sind logisch mathematisch angelehnt.
Und diese Art von Philosophie wird in Großbritannien sehr viel betrieben, auch in den USA
und in Deutschland gab es mal eine Zweiteilung.
Der andere Teil ist die Kontinentalphilosophie, die hat man so bezeichnet, vielleicht weil sie aus dem deutschen Idealismus letztlich auch erwachsen ist.
Aber auch die französische Philosophie zählt sehr stark dazu.
Und da argumentiert man, philosophiert man anders, als man das in der analytischen Philosophie tut.
Die Methode ist eine andere, wenngleich es viele Überlappungen an den Themen gibt,
aber die Methode ist eine andere.
Inwiefern?
Naja, die analytische Philosophie habe ich schon charakterisiert und nur das darf ich mir auch anmaßen.
Das kann ich charakterisieren.
In der kontinentalen Philosophie, die ist vielleicht stärker angelehnt am Literarischen, an Literatur.
Was sich auch darin zeigt, in den USA beispielsweise sind die philosophischen Institute analytisch geprägt,
aber innerhalb der Sprachen, Romanistik, Anglistik und so fort, wird Kontinentalphilosophie betrieben.
Also da sind dann Lacane, Derrida, Foucault sind die Größen, von denen dort gesprochen wird.
Also man zitiert mehr, als dass man allgemeine Denkvorschriften, Denkrezepte anwendet?
Denkvorschriften gibt es sowieso keine, aber es gibt Methoden.
Das war das falsche Wort, Rezepte.
Methoden und Rezepte, wie man gültig schließt, genau.
Und so einen Kanon des gültigen Schließens gibt es vielleicht in der kontinentalen Philosophie nicht
und dort ist aber, da möchte ich mich wirklich nicht drauf festlegen, ist vielleicht auch ein Analogieschluss erhellend.
Also wenn man Metaphern benutzt.
Und Metaphern können natürlich sehr erhellend sein, das wäre aber in der analytischen Philosophie ein Nogo.
Da muss alles logisch aufeinander folgen und man darf nicht frei assoziieren.
Und ist das noch so ein offener Battle, wer da die Nase vorn hat oder existiert das einfach so nebeneinander vor sich hin?
Es gab mal, als ich angefangen habe mit der Promotion, da gab es mal so eine Phase,
da war es auf Konferenzen so, wer das zerstörerischste Gegenargument gegen eine TheHessen hatte, der hatte gewonnen.
Es gab mal so eine Phase, wo das atmosphärisch so war.
Und das war fürchterlich und es hat sich sehr stark gebessert in den letzten Jahren.
Klingt nach Rapbattle irgendwie.
Ja, genau so, richtig.
Rapbattle of Philosophy.
Ja, wer am schnellsten die Silben einem um die Ohren haut, genau.
Schneidige Analyse.
Ja, dieses Projekt „denXte“, das dann erst in der Universität Düsseldorf dann so entstanden ist, nehme ich an?
Genau.
Warum musste es das geben, wie kam es dazu, was war sozusagen die Triebfeder,
hier etwas auf die Beine zu stellen, für das man noch mal eine neue Webseite bauen muss?
Ja, wenn es nur die Webseite wäre.
Damit fängt es ja an.
Ja, damit fängt es an.
Das knüpft ganz gut an an das, was ich vorher gesagt habe.
Weil die analytische Philosophie eben auch ihren Kanon hat, wie man ein gutes Argument aufbaut,
ist sie manchmal etwas schwer zugänglich einerseits, und andererseits kann sie lebensfern wirken.
Wirken, also sie ist es aber nicht.
Und um wieder einen Brückenschlag zu machen von analytisch-philosophischen Fragen hin zur Lebenswelt,
haben wir „denXte“ ins Leben gerufen.
Um eben auch wieder Bürgerinnen und Bürger ohne philosophische Vorkenntnisse wieder mit an Bord zu holen.
Und umgekehrt, um uns auch zu erden.
Denn in philosophischen Fachfragen kann man sich manchmal in Details verlieren,
die dann super interessant sind, aber die eben mit dem Alltäglichen dann weniger zu tun haben.
Und das ist gut und schön und richtig, so muss Wissenschaft funktionieren.
Nur manchmal hat man eben auch das Bedürfnis, wieder das Große und Ganze zu sehen.
Und das beste, was einem passieren kann, ist, wenn man philosophischen Laien dann erklären muss, was man da eigentlich macht.
Und dann hat man sofort wieder die Anbindung an das große und ganze Bild.
Der Kommunikatorpreis ist ja ein Preis für Wissenschaftskommunikation
oder für gelungene Wissenschaftskommunikation.
Das heißt, hier stand eigentlich überhaupt erst mal so der Wunsch oder vielleicht auch die Erkenntnis der Notwendigkeit
der Kommunikation mit einer Öffentlichkeit aus diesem Themenfeld heraus im Vordergrund.
So ist es, ja.
Das war quasi die treibende Kraft?
Hätte man aber auch sein lassen können.
Also man kann ja jetzt auch Professor sein und sich in seinem Kämmerlein einschließen.
Was bringt einen dann sozusagen über diese Schwelle, diese Tür auch wirklich öffnen zu wollen?
Ja, das war ein ureigenes Bedürfnis.
Vielleicht kommt noch hinzu, dass es auch Studierenden manchmal am Beginn ihres Studiums so geht in der Philosophie.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel Logikkurse, die man zunächst mal absolvieren muss innerhalb der analytischen Philosophie.
Und ab und zu geht einem dort abhanden, warum das eigentlich sinnvoll ist.
Und das heißt auch aus der Studierendenperspektive, auch aus meiner eigenen habe ich Logik sehr gerne gemacht,
also das war nicht mein Anlass, aber auch da bin ich selbst als Student auf Fragen gestoßen,
wo mir nicht klar war, warum ich mich philosophisch damit beschäftigen soll.
Und das heißt, das war mir auch ein eigener Antrieb, dann wieder zu sehen,
warum so eine ganz spezielle Fachfrage wiederum wichtig ist für das Große und Ganze.
Das heißt, es ist intrinsisch motiviert.
Einfach um erst mal rauszukommen, das ist die eine Richtung,
auf der anderen Seite, man muss ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht eine Zielgruppe erahnen.
Also gibt es sozusagen auch genug Leute, die schon an die Tür geklopft haben und gesagt haben,
ich will jetzt endlich mal wissen, was ihr da treibt oder muss man sich hier sein Publikum erst suchen?
Ja, wir haben es glücklicherweise sehr schnell gefunden.
Es ist nicht so, dass bei uns in der Uni an die Türen geklopft wird, das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber wenn wir allein an einen Bahnhofszeitschriftenladen gehen, dann sehen wir,
dass Philosophie doch zentral ist, dass das Philosophiemagazin,
in der Zeit gibt es eine Philosophieserie, das liegt ja wirklich direkt auf dem ersten Podest,
wo auch der Spiegel, Fokus und so weiter liegen, da liegt auch das Philosophiemagazin.
Daran erkennt man ja, dass es ein Interesse daran gibt.
Das heißt, wir hatten kaum Zweifel, dass wir nicht ein Publikum finden
und in der Tat war es dann auch glücklicherweise so, dass wir innerhalb von drei Veranstaltungen Leute nach Hause schicken mussten,
weil der Saal einfach nicht so viele Leute fasste.
Was für Leute interessiert das?
Also ist das eine Altersfrage?
Na es war keine Altersfrage, es ist wirklich queerbeet.
Wir haben Schulklassen als Gäste und dann bis zu Pensionären, Rentnern, die zu uns kommen.
Also vom Alter her ist es querbeet.
Soziologisch haben wir keine Studien angestellt, das wissen wir nicht.
Aber es ist eine große Vielfalt.
Wenn man auf unsere Seite www.denXte.de schaut, da gibt es ja Bilder des Publikums
und da sieht man eine große Spanne, eine große Diversität im Publikum.
Und gibt es irgendetwas, was über die Altersgrenzen hinweg dieses Publikum eint
oder gibt es da noch mehrere sich unterscheidende Achsen?
Was es eint ist wahrscheinlich ein Grundinteresse an philosophischen Fragen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, vielleicht wird der eine oder die andere mitgebracht und denkt dann,
ja gut, dann komme ich halt mal mit und gewinnt dann auch Interesse an der Philosophie, das mag sein.
Aber ich glaube, wer zu uns findet, hat schon selbst ein genuines Interesse an philosophischen Fragestellungen oder philosophischen Themen.
In Forschergeist Ausgabe Nummer 31 habe ich das schöne Thema Abenteuer Mathematik behandelt,
habe ich mit Günter Ziegler gesprochen und soweit ich mich jetzt spontan daran erinnere, habe ich einiges schon mal gehört.
Weil so bisschen wie die Philosophie ist auch die Mathematik so ein bisschen so eine metaphysische Disziplin,
die eigentlich überall drin steckt, aber nicht sozusagen der Kern der eigentlichen Forschung ist,
es sei denn, man beschäftigt sich halt nur mit Mathematik oder primär mit Mathematik.
Und Philosophie scheint mir auch so ein bisschen so eine Universallehre zu sein,
die Anwendung finden kann auf alle Bereiche, und die auch in gewisser Hinsicht eine Verheißung verspricht.
Es ist halt bei der Mathematik, die von uns anfangs schon so entdeckte Klarheit über die Abzählbarkeit und über die Strukturen des Wesens von allem,
lauert ja bei der Philosophie auch dieses Versprechens einer andere Klarheit, der Klarheit über das Warum und Wieso überhaupt.
Ja.
Fiel mir gerade so ein, dass das irgendwie offensichtlich eine gewisse Verwandtschaft zu haben scheint
oder haben könnte.
Auf jeden Fall.
Manchmal sagt man von Teilen der analytischen Philosophie, dass das so eine Mathematik der Begriffe ist.
Statt mit Zahlen rechnet man da mit Begriffen und Konzepten.
Ich meine, wenn Logik da am Anfang steht, dann ist es von Mathematik so weit nicht entfernt oder vielleicht auch von Informatik.
Richtig, da gibt es große Gemeinsamkeiten.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei denXte, und jetzt habe ich schon gehört, also es gibt Ausspielungen aller Arten und Weisen.
Podcasts sind geplant, Veranstaltungen haben stattgefunden, erzählen Sie mal so ein bisschen,
wie Sie so da zu einem Plan gekommen sind und zu einem Vorgehen.
War das mehr so Learning by Doing oder eher Masterplan?
Weil um Wissenschaft effektiv zu kommunizieren, ich meine, das heißt ja auch, das ist eine Menge Arbeit,
das klang ja schon an, sieben Leute braucht es, damit da überhaupt irgendwas passiert.
Gerade wenn man eben so breitbandig agiert und dann sollte man natürlich eben schauen,
dass man seine Energien ja vielleicht auch wohldosiert und die geringen Mittel dann auch wohl orientiert ausrichtet.
Wie sind Sie da vorgegangen und was waren so die ersten Schritte und die ersten Erfolgserlebnisse oder auch negativen, sind immer die besten.
Ja, natürlich gab es sehr viel Learning by Doing, aber wir hatten in der Tat einen Masterplan.
Wir hatten eine Kernidee und das zeigt sich ja auch im Namen, den ich gleich gerne noch mal erläutere.
Ja.
Kern unserer Abende sind immer philosophische Gedankenexperimente.
Und ich gebe Ihnen mal eins.
Ja, her damit.
Ja, also stellen Sie sich vor, Sie sind auf einer Party und amüsieren sich da ziemlich gut.
Sie haben zu Hause versprochen eigentlich, dass Sie um 22 Uhr schon wieder zurück sind,
aber weil es so viel Spaß macht, bleiben Sie halt noch da.
Und Sie gehen erst um 24 Uhr, Sie entscheiden sich dann erst und gehen dann.
Was Sie nicht wussten, und was keiner der Gäste wusste, auch der Gastgeber wusste das nicht, ist,
dass die Türschließanlage ausgerechnet in den zwei Stunden kaputt gegangen ist und die Türen waren verriegelt.
Sie hätten gar nicht gehen können.
Jetzt ist meine Frage an Sie, sind Sie trotzdem moralisch für Ihre Verspätung verantwortlich?
Denn Sie haben ja entschieden, länger da zu bleiben, Ihr Versprechen nicht einzuhalten,
aber Sie hätten nicht früher gehen können.
Und was ist jetzt die Frage, die ich beantworten muss?
Sind Sie moralisch verantwortlich für Ihre Verspätung?
Moralisch verantwortlich.
Also gestehe ich es ein oder verschweige ich es, ist das die Frage?
Naja, ob Sie es verschweigen oder nicht, Sie sind entweder verantwortlich oder nicht.
Natürlich kann man vieles verschweigen, was man so verbockt, aber man hat es verbockt und ist demnach trotzdem verantwortlich.
Okay.
Also jetzt spontan würde ich natürlich sagen,
dass ich in meinem Anflug von Selbstzweifel in dem Moment natürlich dann eine höhere moralische Legitimation im Nachhinein entnehme,
dadurch dass es hätte sowieso nicht funktionieren können.
Ja ist eine interessante Intuition.
Viele glauben, dass es trotzdem eine Art der freien Willensentscheidung war, weil Sie das frei entschieden haben.
Die Entscheidung haben Sie selbst in sich selbst getroffen und von daher bleiben Sie moralisch verantwortlich,
auch wenn Sie nicht hätten anders handeln können.
Aber das ist in der Philosophie natürlich streitbar.
Aber an einem solchen Gedankenexperiment sehen Sie, dass man sehr schnell zu einer interessanten Frage kommt,
dass aber trotzdem in ein Narrativ einbindet, was allen sehr schnell zugänglich ist.
Und deswegen haben wir Gedankenexperimente als Kern unserer denXte-Abende gewählt.
Und jetzt wird auch das X erklärlich, das ist das X für Experiment.
Und es gibt noch eine zweite Ebene, dieses X das ist, dass wir partizipativ die Abende gestalten.
Ich frage dort auch das Publikum, wie würden Sie sich entscheiden
oder ist das moralisch verwerflich was Sie gemacht haben oder eben nicht?
Und dann können die Leute mit einem Smartphone-Tool eben Stellung beziehen und wählen.
Ja, die Person ist moralisch verantwortlich oder nein, sie ist es nicht.
Und dann gucken wir uns das Stimmungsbild an.
Und das X ist dann natürlich auch das Ankreuzen der Ja oder Nein-Frage,
der ich bin dagegen oder ich bin dafür Frage, so erklärt sich das X in denXte.
Ich stelle also fest, dass es dann zur theoretischen Philosophie tatsächlich auch die experimentelle Philosophie gibt,
die sich dann hier im Rahmen dieser Veranstaltung zeigt.
Die experimentelle, es gibt in der Tat experimentelle Philosophie
und die ist in der Tat, die legt sehr vielen Probanden eben solche Gedankenexperimente vor
und schaut sich dann an, wie die Mehrheit auf ein bestimmtes Szenario reagiert.
Das heißt, da wird dann auch gemeinsam diskutiert oder wird das Ganze nur von der Bühne her erläutert?
Nein, nein, bei uns bei denXte wird selbstverständlich diskutiert.
Es ist so, dass wir das Gedankenexperiment, unser Gast macht das immer,
präsentiert ihr/sein Gedankenexperiment.
Und dann machen wir allerdings erst mal eine Abstimmung aus dem Bauch heraus,
also einfach per Intuition, ohne philosophisches Vorwissen und schauen uns dann das Ergebnis an.
Und im Anschluss daran stellt unser Gast dann historisch, philosophisch vor,
was Philosophinnen und Philosophen schon zum Thema gesagt haben.
Gibt also theoretisches Futter, wie Philosophinnen und Philosophen darüber nachgedacht haben.
Und danach gibt es dann einen ganz großen Frage- und Antwortblock,
wo das Publikum Fragen stellen kann und mit dem Gast, mit uns, mit dem denXte-Team diskutieren kann.
Und das auch tut?
Und das auch tut, jaja, wir könnten den Abend quasi unendlich ausdehnen.
Irgendwann müssen wir dann zum Ende des Abends kommen,
aber ja die Beteiligung ist erfreulich hoch und ich denke, für beide Seiten,
mindestens aber für uns, für das Team und unseren Gast, immer enorm fruchtbar,
weil, wie ich eben gesagt habe, es geht uns ja darum, die akademische Philosophie wieder an das Leben anzubinden
und das geschieht dann dort.
Wir sehen dann wieder die Perspektiven, die man hat, wenn man noch nicht ganz theoretisch über diese Fragen noch nachdenkt.
Werden dann im Wesentlichen schon solche Sachen eingetütet, die jetzt schon irgendwie seit hunderten Jahren diskutiert werden
und die an Aktualität nicht verlieren oder hat das Ganze auch so einen aktuelleren Anstrich mit Fragen,
die vielleicht bisher als ungelöst gelten?
Einen aktuellen Anstrich hat das auf jeden Fall.
Wenn wir das Gedankenexperiment, was ich ja gerade gezeigt habe, das ist die uralte Frage nach moralischer Verantwortlichkeit.
Nach einerseits Willensfreiheit, war das mein freier Wille zu bleiben, ja oder nein,
obwohl ich nicht anders hätte handeln können, ich hätte ja nicht gehen können,
war das trotzdem eine freie Willensentscheidung.
Und in dem Falle, denke ich, hat man die Intuition, dass es so ist.
Und solche Fragen nach moralischer Verantwortlichkeit und dem freien Willen sind ja juristisch sehr relevant.
Ob jemand hätte anders handeln können oder nicht.
Weswegen da für eine Handlung eben juristisch auch verantwortlich machen.
Nicht nur moralisch, sondern auch juristisch verantwortlich machen.
Deswegen sind wir da auch gleich in der Lebenswelt angekommen.
Aber es gibt andere Sachen.
Sie kennen vielleicht den Trolley-Case, wo eine Eisenbahn auf einem Gleis auf eine Gruppe von fünf Leuen zufährt
und Sie beobachten das und Sie wissen, der Zug ist nicht mehr zu bremsen,
der ist zu massiv, zu schnell, der schafft das nicht, der Bremsweg ist viel zu lang.
Bremsen geht nicht mehr.
Und Sie können die Leute auch nicht warnen, weil die zu weit wegstehen, Sie erreichen die nicht, können die nicht rufen.
Sie haben eine Möglichkeit, Sie können eine Weiche umstellen, dann fährt der Zug auf ein anderes Gleis,
dort steht aber eine andere Person, eine Einzelperson und die können Sie auch nicht warnen,
die würde also von dem Zug überrollt, wenn Sie die Weiche umstellen.
Wenn Sie nichts tun, dann werden die fünf Personen überrollt.
Was machen Sie jetzt in diesem Beispiel?
Welche moralische sehr schwierige Entscheidung treffen Sie hier?
Retten Sie die fünf, dadurch wird allerdings eine Person getötet durch den Zug.
Oder lassen Sie dem Zug seinen Lauf.
Dem Schicksal seinen Lauf.
Und dann werden die fünf erfasst?
Das Trolley-Problem hatten wir in der politischen Auseinandersetzung in Deutschland vor einigen Jahren,
bei der Diskussion um Abschießen von Flugzeugen, die potenziell zu einem Terrorwaffe werden könnten.
Da wurde es auch schon mal genutzt, ganz genau.
Und jetzt sind solche Züge und solche Terroranschläge, die könnten passieren,
aber es ist ja doch glücklicherweise relativ unwahrscheinlich.
Ich sage nicht, dass das nicht passieren kann, aber es passiert halt nicht sehr häufig.
Und so ein Zugbeispiel scheint ja im luftleeren Raum zu passieren.
Und was ich aber eigentlich zeigen wollte ist, ganz und gar nicht.
Denken Sie an autonom fahrende Fahrzeuge, Autos.
Die können ja in die Situation kommen, dass ein Kind auf die Straße rennt,
das Auto errechnet blitzschnell, weil diese Rechenkapazität hat es,
rechnet blitzschnell, der Bremsweg ist zu lang, ich muss also ausweichen,
ich, das Auto, muss ausweichen, jetzt sind wir wieder beim Ich-Bewusstsein,
das das Auto bestimmt nicht hat, aber es muss ausweichen.
Wenn jetzt aber auf dem Bürgersteig, die einzige Möglichkeit, wo es hin ausweichen könnte,
zwei ältere Menschen spazieren gehen, was soll das Auto machen?
Und jetzt sind wir im echten Leben im Trolley-Beispiel.
Und bei dem Trolley-Beispiel können wir irgendwie noch die Augen verschließen und sagen,
ach damit will ich mich nicht beschäftigen, das interessiert mich nicht
oder mit solchen moralischen Fragen möchte ich nichts zu tun haben.
Aber im Autofall muss es ja programmiert werden.
Wenn wir es nicht programmieren, dann überlassen wir auch wieder dem Schicksal seinen Lauf,
dann kann das Auto tun was es will, ich mache jetzt so Anführungszeichen in die Luft,
weil es natürlich keinen Wille hat.
Aber wenn wir das nicht einprogrammieren, dann passiert ja auch irgendwas in solchen Situationen.
Das heißt, hier haben wir eine direkte moralische Verantwortung, uns Gedanken darüber zu machen,
was diese Autos in solchen Fällen tun sollen und wie das dann einprogrammiert wird.
Gegeben natürlich, das ist vielleicht noch ein bisschen Zukunftsmusik, dass das Auto das Szenario auch genauso erkennt,
wie ich das eben beschrieben habe.
Das muss ja in der Lage sein, eine Person und zwei andere zu erkennen, deren Alter einzuschätzen und so fort.
Das muss natürlich gegeben sein.
Aber davon sind wir, glaube ich, nicht so weit entfernt.
Wie wird das Trolley-Problem gemeinhin beantwortet?
Wie häufig, gibt es natürlich verschiedene Antwortmöglichkeiten.
Es gibt verschiedene Ethiken, die dann unterschiedlich auf das Trolley-Problem reagieren.
Die an sich natürlich auch wieder ihre Schwierigkeiten haben.
Ich will Ihnen zwei Antwortmöglichkeiten geben.
Es gibt den sogenannten Konsequentialismus, da steckt das Wort Konsequenz drin
und diese Ethik sagt, eine Handlung ist dann gut, oder besser als eine andere,
wenn die Konsequenzen für die meisten Menschen die besseren sind bei dieser Handlungsalternative.
Eine Konsequentialistin würde also im Trolley-Beispiel antworten müssen, welche Handlung ist die moralisch richtige, gute Handlung.
Ja die, die die meisten rettet oder am wenigsten Schaden zufügt.
Das Glück der meisten hervorruft.
Also Weiche umstellen.
Es gibt auch Ethiken, die ontologischen Ethiken, die sich beispielsweise auf einen Kanon verlassen,
die 10 Gebote, das wäre so ein paradigmatisches Beispiel einer solchen Ethik.
Die sagt, hier gibt es Grundsätze, an denen wir nicht rütteln wollen.
Zum Beispiel du sollst nicht töten.
Und wenn man selbst die Weiche umstellt, ist man ja mindestens kausal verantwortlich für den Tod des einen auf dem anderen Gleis.
Und wenn du das nicht tun sollst, dann darfst du da nicht einschreiten.
Oder eben eine Ethik die sagt, Menschenleben, auch die Anzahl von Menschenleben dürfen nicht gegeneinander abgewogen werden.
Das heißt, ob fünf oder eins, hier sind wir blind dieser Zahl gegenüber
und deswegen kann die Weiche auch so stehen bleiben wie sie ist.
Das sind verschiedene Optionen, die man hat, hier zu antworten.
Zu dieser Frage mit dem Flugzeugabschuss hat ja letzten Endes das Bundesverfassungsgericht sich, glaube ich, geäußert.
Da ist ja eigentlich die Rechtssprechung, also die Verfassungsrechtssprechung eine philosophische Frage.
Also die haben sich ja quasi positioniert und haben gesagt, wir schalten die Weiche nicht.
Ja.
Also sozusagen die ontologische Philosophie an der Stelle.
Wie nehmen Sie das denn so wahr, dass juristisches, also Juristik, Jura, juristische Arbeit, Gesetze,
sind ja im Prinzip so in Stein gehauene oder zumindest gebaute Maschinentexte,
die versuchen sollen, eine empfundene Ethik der Gesellschaft, die sozusagen unseren Regeln,
unseren Vorstellungen, unseren Wünschen, unseren Meinungen entspricht,
in einen Handlungsrahmen abzubilden.
Dass man sagen kann, okay, in einer beliebigen Situation schaue ich jetzt einfach in den Gesetzestext rein und dann ist es das.
Und in dem Moment, wo man quasi auf Verfassungsebene so eine Entscheidung macht,
dann ist das ja eine unmittelbare Anwendung solcher philosophischer Prinzipien.
Ja.
Gibt es da so viel Berührung mit Jura?
Ja klar, natürlich gibt es die Philosophie, die isch genau mit diesem Thema beschäftigt.
Wir hatten am Anfang die Unterscheidung, theoretische Philosophie, praktische Philosophie,
und die praktische Philosophie beschäftigt sich auch mit der Philosophie der Juristerei.
Und da ist es natürlich so, dass wir intuitiv hoffen, dass die Gesetze auch unsere moralischen Intuitionen auffangen oder aufgreifen.
Aber wenn sie denn mal geschrieben sind, dann ist es ja oft so, dass sie sich entfernen
oder jedenfalls keine Moralurteile sind, sondern dann eben wirklich nur juristische Urteile sind.
Deswegen habe ich eben auch gesagt, ob jemand moralisch oder juristisch verantwortlich ist für etwas,
das muss man dann fein auseinanderhalten.
Ja auf jeden Fall.
Man kommt sehr schnell immer wieder auf die Metaebene, weil es letzten Endes hier so ein bisschen auch das Prinzip zu sein scheint.
Es gibt ja auch diesen Begriff der Metaphysik, die sozusagen quasi den Kern darstellt der Philosophie,
kann man das so sagen?
Da würden die praktischen Philosophinnen widersprechen.
Es ist jedenfalls ein wichtiges Fachgebiet innerhalb der Philosophie.
Die Metaphysik, die sich eben damit beschäftigt, was gibt es und wie hängt das miteinander zusammen.
Aber andere wichtige Gebiete gibt es genau gleichberechtigt daneben.
Beispielweise die Erkenntnistheorie.
Wir wollen ja auch wissen, was ist Wissen überhaupt, wann können wir von einer Person gerechtfertigterweise sagen,
dass sie etwas weiß, wie erlangen wir überhaupt Wissen, welche Wissenswege,
welche Wissensquellen stehen uns denn eigentlich offen?
Das sind ja neben den moralischen Fragen ebenso wichtige philosophische Fragen.
Und insofern ist die Metaphysik eine dieser großen Bereiche.
Es wird in der Philosophie oft gestritten, was denn die erste Philosophie ist.
Ja und da wurde die Metaphysik oft genannt als die ersten, die vielleicht auch historisch als erstes philosophisches Fachgebiet ins Leben gerufen wurde.
Durch Thales beispielsweise, nennt man oft so als einen der ersten Philosophen und Mathematiker,
kennen wir wahrscheinlich vom Thales-Kreis noch aus der Schulzeit her.
Er hat auch eine Sonnenfinsternis vorhergesagt.
Aber da stehen die ersten philosophischen Fragen, die stehen, sind eben die, woraus besteht die Welt.
Und erst im Nachhinein kommen dann lebenspraktische Fragen dazu,
die in den philosophischen Kanon aufgenommen sind.
Also historisch, was zumindest die westliche Philosophie betrifft, die ihren Ursprung in Griechenland hat,
hat die Metaphysik so schon ihren, kann die Ansprüche stellen, da die erste Philosophie gewesen zu sein.
Ich finde das ein sehr interessantes Wort.
Weil das wirkt erst mal merkwürdig, weil wir auch so eine Prägung auf Physik haben.
Wissen Sie, wo es herkommt oder was vermuten Sie, wo es herkommt?
Naja, ich bin ja schlecht in solchen Sachen.
Ich sehe mir nur gerade die Übersetzung und die Herleitung, wie sie jetzt in der Wikipedia verankert ist,
also jetzt rein von dem Wortstamm her.
Also Meta, ich sage mal so, jenseits, drüber, danach.
So und Physis einfach die Natur oder die natürliche Beschaffenheit.
Also das ist sozusagen, Metaphysik ist so die Frage nach dem Jenseits der Natur.
Was ist dahinter.
Okay.
Aber ich lasse mich auf andere Definitionen gerne ein.
Das ist natürlich keine schlechte Definition.
Ein erster Anhaltspunkt kann natürlich die Etymologie sein
oder dass man so einen Begriff mal auseinandernimmt.
Und Meta als hinter und Physis die Natur hinter der Natur, das ist gar nicht so übel.
Es gibt eine Anekdote.
Es gibt die Anekdote, dass der erste Bibliothekar, der die aristotelischen Schriftengeordnet hat,
Andronikos von Rhodos, der hat ein Buch von Aristoteles hinter die Schriften,
die Aristoteles „Die Physik“ genannt hat, dieses Werk hat er hinter diese Bücher gestellt
und daher kam die Metaphysik, hinter der Physik.
Ob diese Anekdote jetzt wahr ist, das sei mal dahingestellt.
Es würde aber auch inhaltlich ganz gut passen.
Nur was soll das heißen, hinter dem Natürlichen?
Beschäftigt sich die Metaphysik mit Spekulativem, mit Esoterik oder
das scheint ja so darauf hinauszulaufen.
Und das ist es dezidiert nicht.
Es geht nicht um Spekulationen, es geht auch nicht um Esoterik.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel dafür, wo man sehen kann, dass wir über das, was Physikerinnen und Physiker machen, hinausgehen.
Was machen die denn in ihren Labors?
Naja unter anderem wollen die die Naturgesetze rausfinden.
Die wollen wissen, ah E=mc2 oder F=M*A.
Das erste ist das newtonsche Energie- und Masseäquivalenz, das andere ist das newtonsche Kraftgesetz.
Und solche Gesetze wollen ja Physikerinnen und Physiker rausfinden in ihren Laboratorien.
Und jetzt kann man aber die Frage stellen, was macht denn eigentlich ein Naturgesetz aus?
Was ist das denn eigentlich, ein Naturgesetz, was haben die denn alle gemeinsam?
Dieses E=mc2 oder dieses F=M*A.
Und da fragt man eben nach Kriterien dafür, wann etwas unter diesen Begriff Naturgesetz fallen kann.
Und vielleicht ist das erste, was einem so einfallen kann, naja das muss irgendwie ein allgemeiner Satz sein.
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, hier auf dem Tisch vor uns steht ein Glas.
Ist das ein Naturgesetz? Nein, das handelt ja nur von dem Glas.
Naturgesetz muss irgendwie von allen Massen handeln.
Es muss von allen Elektronen irgendwie die Rede sein, also es muss ein ganz allgemeiner Satz sein.
Und es muss Voraussagen liefern können, die man überprüfen kann.
Und es muss Voraussagen liefern können, ganz genau.
Es muss also in die Zukunft projizierbar sein und da möglichst eben auch gerechtfertigte wahre Vorhersagen treffen können.
Das muss mit Naturgesetzen auch geschehen können.
Aber das kann man manchmal auch mit allgemeinen Aussagen.
Beispielsweise dass morgen mein Wecker auch wieder klingeln wird.
Ja, gut, aber das ist kein Naturgesetz, dass der gestellt ist und so weiter.
Also manchmal können wir solche Vorhersagen…
Es kann auch sein, dass er nicht klingelt.
Genau, und da kommen wir jetzt zu einem weiteren Kriterium von Naturgesetzlichkeit,
die gelten irgendwie mit Notwendigkeit, da gibt es kein Drumherum, das können wir nicht vermeiden.
C, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit, ist die höchste Geschwindigkeit, sie können nichts höher als das Licht beschleunigen.
Das geht nicht.
Das heißt, die Naturgesetze sind irgendwie auch Dinger, Regeln, die unumstößlich sind.
Die können wir nicht verhindern.
Und damit zusammen hängt noch etwas.
Also die sind auch dafür verantwortlich, dass verschiedene wenn-dann-Sätze wahr sind.
Also noch mal um auf das Glas hier zurückzukommen,
ließe ich das jetzt hier auf den Boden fallen, dann würde das zersplittern.
Und das ist wohl wahr, ich werde es nicht machen, aber trotzdem,
also das ist ja ein Satz, der ist wahr, obwohl er faktisch gerade,
jedenfalls sein erstes Satz, der Antezedens, der Vordersatz des Satzes,
wenn ich es runterfallen ließe, der ist faktisch falsch, ich tue es ja nicht.
Also der ist nicht gegeben.
Und trotzdem scheine ich ja etwas richtiges über die Welt zu sagen,
obwohl ich nichts faktisches über die Welt sage, nicht wie es faktisch ist,
sondern ich mache eine was-wäre-wenn-Aussage.
Und solche was-wäre-wenn-Aussagen sind gestützt, wenn sie wahr sind,
sind sie gestützt durch Naturgesetze auch.
Naja, warum ist dieser wenn-dann-Satz war?
Ja, weil das Glas eine bestimmte Molekülstruktur hat und die zerbricht,
die reißt, die ist nicht, die molekularen Bindungen sind eben nicht so stark,
dass sie bei so einem Aufprall, bei so einem Impuls, der auf das Glas einwirkt,
dass sie dann nicht zerreißen würden, die zerreißen bei dieser Art von Impuls.
Das heißt, das ist naturgesetzlich abgedeckt, dass dieser Satz wahr ist.
Und deswegen haben Naturgesetze auch so eine was-wäre-wenn-Kraft.
Die sagen uns auch, nicht nur was faktisch ist, sondern die erstrecken sich auch über den Möglichkeitsraum,
was passieren könnte oder was passieren muss.
Nicht einfach nur passiert, sondern passieren muss.
Sondern all das, was wir jetzt gemeinsam erdacht haben hier über die Naturgesetze,
ist nicht die Kernaufgabe der Physik.
Die findet nämlich raus, welche Naturgesetze gibt es, aber nicht, was ist eigentlich ein Naturgesetz?
Welche Eigenschaften hat denn so ein Naturgesetz?
Das ist eine philosophische Frage.
Und deswegen geht diese philosophische Frage über die Physik hinaus.
Bedeutet natürlich nicht, dass die einen oder der andere Physiker nicht auch daran sehr interessiert ist an solchen Fragen
und das betreibt, aber jedenfalls nicht im Labor.
Welches Experiment wollten Sie denn anstellen, um zeigen zu können,
was ein Naturgesetz ist, statt welches gibt es hier gerade zu untersuchen.
Was ja auch so ein bisschen mit durchklingt ist, dass es ja auch eine Aufgabe der Philosophie ist,
überhaupt erst mal zu ordnen.
Ontologie, der Begriff klang ja schon an, ist ja letztlich im Prinzip die Bereitstellung von Begriffsmaterial
und von Abstraktionswerkzeugen, die überhaupt erst mal einordnen,
was ist es überhaupt, was ich beschreiben kann und mit welchen Worten tue ich es
und wann ist dieses Wort angemessen, wann ist dieses Wort?
Man sammelt ja quasi erst mal so seinen Wortschatz beisammen
und fügt den in so einen Strukturbaukasten, aus dem man sich bedienen kann,
um überhaupt erst mal die Welt beschreiben zu können mit einer allgemeinen Sprache,
die dann im Idealfall ja auch disziplinübergreifend zur Anwendung kommen.
Sie haben das gerade Ontologie genannt, ich würde das Begriffsdefinition nennen, was Sie gerade beschrieben haben.
Ontologie ist eher die Lehre vom Sein, also was gibt es und was bedeutet es eigentlich zu sein.
Und beschäftigt sich also direkt mit den Dingen.
Die Begriffsklärung, Begriffe bereitzustellen, das ist dann eher,
ja, ich habe es Begriffsklärung genannt, während die Ontologie sich mit Dingen und nicht Begriffe beschäftigt.
Mhm /bejahend/, okay.
Vielleicht ist hier so ein bisschen meine informatische Prägung bisschen reingekommen,
weil in der Welt Ontologie sehr wohl so zur Verwendung kommt.
Stimmt, in der Informatik wird das so ähnlich gebraucht, ich erinnere mich.
In der Philosophie nicht, da ist es die Lehre vom Seienden oder die Lehre davon,
was es grundsätzlich gibt, das ist eine ontologische Frage.
Also eigentlich genau das gleiche wie Metaphysik.
Ja, da gibt es eine große Überlappung, manchmal wird das in einen Topf geschmissen,
ich unterscheide das gerne und sage, die Ontologie beschäftigt sich eben rein mit der Frage, was gibt es.
Während die Metaphysik darüber hinaus, die Ontologie ist ein Teilbereich der Metaphysik,
die Metaphysik fragt darüber hinaus noch die Frage, wie hängt das eigentlich alles miteinander zusammen?
Da gibt es naturgesetzliche Zusammenhänge, Kausalzusammenhänge,
konstitutive Zusammenhänge, also beispielsweise, ich komme immer wieder auf das Glas zurück,
das Glas wird ja konstituiert durch seine Moleküle.
Und da sind wir direkt in der ontologischen Frage drin, gibt es das Glas eigentlich wirklich
oder gibt es nicht eigentlich „nur“ die Moleküle, die glasförmig geformt sind.
Und das ist eigentlich das, was es wirklich gibt und das Glas ist irgendwie darauf reduzierbar
und hat einen geringeren Seinszustand sozusagen als es die Teile haben, aus denen es besteht.
Wenn man jetzt versucht, der Öffentlichkeit Philosophie entgegenzubringen,
ist denn diese Unbestimmtheit und dass man die Dinge nicht abschließend wirklich genau sagen kann,
ja da ist es jetzt genau so und da ist dann irgendwie Schluss.
Also das ist das, was ich so ein bisschen heraushöre.
Also es gibt zwar sehr viel Ordnungswunsch und auch Ordnungskraft,
aber am Ende ist alles ja der Interpretation überlassen und so bisschen…
Manchmal habe ich so den Eindruck, es ist so ein bisschen wie mit diesen nicht newtonischen Flüssigkeiten,
wo man dann halt irgendwie, wenn man jetzt so Stärke und Wasser mischt,
solange man es bearbeitet hat es irgendwie eine Struktur, kaum schaut man sich sein Werk an, zerfließt es wie Wasser.
Wie sind so die Erkenntnisprozesse und Aha-Momente, wenn man jetzt im Rahmen der denXte-Veranstaltungen dann mit den Leuten interagiert?
Was kommt bei raus, was bleibt hängen, was ergibt sich daraus?
Also es ist schon richtig, das verschiedene philosophische Fragen über die Jahrhunderte hinweg immer wieder aufkamen
und anders beantwortet wurden.
Ein Philosoph zu Beginn des 20. Jahrhunderts, Whitehead hat einmal gesagt,
dass alle Philosophie eigentlich nur Fußnoten zu Platon ist.
Und von daher ist es schon richtig, dass viele philosophische Fragen immer wieder aufkommen und neue Antworten finden.
Es ist aber trotzdem so, dass es auf eine gewisse Weise auch philosophischen Fortschritt gibt.
Wir loten nämlich den Raum der möglichen Antworten aus.
Sie haben es eben so schön beschrieben, man versucht mit einer Flüssigkeit zu handhaben,
sobald das Gefäß weg ist, dann zerfließt das wieder alles.
Aber wir stellen in der Philosophie, um in der Metapher zu bleiben, eine ganze Menge zur Verfügung,
mit denen man diese Flüssigkeit auffangen kann.
Und da gibt es dann durchaus auch Fortschritt und sei es auch nur manchmal ein Negativfortschritt im Sinne von,
man weiß halt wie es nicht geht.
Wir hatten bei denXte beispielsweise die Frage, was ist Wissen?
Wann ist es richtig von jemanden zu sagen, dass er oder sie etwas weiß und stimmt das?
Und dazu hat Platon auch schon Definitionsversuche gegeben
und wir wissen, dass verschiedene einfach falsch sind oder dass die nicht ganz zum Ziel führen, nur so halb zum Ziel führen.
Das Beispiel ist das folgende:
Was könnte das denn sein? Wann könnte es denn richtig sein, von einer Person zu sagen,
dass sie etwas weiß?
Naja, ein Punkt ist doch der, dass sie selbst daran glauben muss, muss selbst diese Meinung haben.
Man kann schlecht sagen, ich weiß, dass wir hier in Berlin sind, aber ich glaube das nicht.
Dann denkt man, wie was meinst du jetzt, du weißt, dass du in Berlin bist, aber du glaubst es nicht, was soll denn das heißen?
Also irgendwie muss es doch so sein, dass eine Person, die etwas weiß,
die glaubt auch in erster Linie daran, dass es so ist.
Also Wissen hat schon mal irgendwas mit einer Meinung zu tun und man hat eine Meinung.
Aber man hat mehr als Meinungen.
Die Meinung ist ja dem Wissen nachgelagert, die ergibt sich ja sozusagen daraus.
Nachgelagert oder vorgelagert, je nachdem aus welcher Perspektive man guckt, genau.
Eine bloße Meinung reicht ja wohl nicht zu Wissen.
Also wenn ich jetzt der Meinung bin, dass die nächsten Lottozahlen so und so und so sind,
das reicht ja wohl für Wissen nicht aus.
Sondern ich brauche irgendwie eine Begründung.
Oder wir alle von Reptiloiden regiert werden.
Oder das, genau.
Das ist auch eine sehr beliebte Meinung.
Das ist auch eine Meinung und man darf auch frei die Meinung vertreten,
aber so richtig diskursfähig und wertvoll und interessant werden Meinungen ja erst dann,
wenn sie begründete Meinungen sind, wenn sie gerechtfertigte Meinungen sind.
Wenn man sagen kann, warum man diese Meinung hat, warum sie denn richtig ist.
Das heißt, bloße Meinung ist kein Wissen, also bloß zu meinen,
dass wir von Reptilien regiert werden, dann weiß man das halt nicht,
sondern man muss eben Begründungen mitbringen.
Ist ein bisschen dünne auf jeden Fall.
Genau, also wenn ich weiß, dass das Glas, wenn ich behaupten will,
ich weiß, dass das Glas zerbricht, wenn ich das runterfallen lasse, dann muss ich schon Gründe geben.
So was wie, naja ich kenne mich mit Glas aus, das ist halt so eine amorphe Molekülgeschichte
und dann habe ich eben meine Begründung.
So und letztlich reicht das aber auch noch nicht, also die Begründung kann noch so gut sein,
und man kann noch so stark daran glauben, es muss auch noch wahr sein.
Ich kann ja schlecht sagen, ich weiß, dass wir hier in Köln sind, ich habe auch gute Gründe
ich gucke nämlich raus und sehe auch einen Fernsehturm, das ist mein Grund dafür,
sehe ich in Köln auch, habe also begründete Meinung, aber das kann ja wohl kein Wissen sein,
denn das ist einfach falsch, wir sind hier nicht in Köln, sondern wir sind in Berlin.
Also zu Wissen gehört es wohl doch auch noch, dass die gerechtfertigte Meinung wahr ist.
Wenn es nicht wahr ist, was ich glaube, kann ich ja wohl kaum sagen, ich weiß es.
So und jetzt haben wir /unverständlich/
Und daran zweifelt man kaum, an Wahrheit und Meinung wird niemand zweifeln,
dass das Grundelemente von Wissen sind.
Das Wissen das mit sich bringen muss, sonst kann man nicht von Wissen sprechen.
Und so hat die Philosophie eben auch für Definitionen von Naturgesetz,
für Definition von Kausalität sich so einen Grundstamm erarbeitet von Möglichkeiten,
wie es denn explizierbar ist, auf den sich alle immer wieder erneut beziehen und davon ausgehen
und vielleicht die ein oder andere These verneinen und andere anbieten.
Aber dieser Grundstamm des Argumentierens bleibt dann bestehen.
Wer sich mit der Frage beschäftigt, was ist wissen, muss dazu Stellung nehmen,
wie sieht es mit Meinungen aus, wie sieht es mit Wahrheit aus, wie sieht es mit Rechtfertigung aus?
Sind das Elemente für deinen Begriff von Wissen oder sind das keine,
und wenn nicht, warum nicht?
Also jede, die sich damit beschäftigt, wird diese Grundelemente wieder mit verwenden.
Und das hat sich die Philosophie erarbeitet.
Jetzt ist ja, wo wir gerade bei Glauben sind, steht ja auch die Philosophie oder stand schon immer stark im Wettstreit mit der Religion.
Die so ein bisschen auch die Wahrheit ein wenig gepachtet hat, also die Aussage darüber, was denn nun…
Sie glaubt das zu tun.
Ja, aber das ist ja, sagen wir mal, das Problem, was man sozusagen mit der Auseinandersetzung damit hat,
dass der Glaube, der ja, wie wir jetzt gerade hergeleitet haben, kein gesichertes Wissen darstellen kann,
über allem steht und wenn man nur ausreichend daran glaubt, dann wird es auch schon so sein.
Und da kommen dann halt alle möglichen Geistwesen, die in Wolken leben und so weiter,
das ist ja, sagen wir mal, noch eine sehr verbreitete Sicht der Dinge, so.
Also vielleicht nicht unbedingt so sehr im wissenschaftlichen Umfeld,
da würde ich sagen, ist das eher ein weniger populärer Blick auf die Welt,
aber wenn man jetzt so die gesamte Bevölkerung oder auch unsere Gesellschaft erst mal nur anschaut,
dann ist es ja sehr verbreitet.
Wie kann so etwas, wie kann man da vermitteln, wie kann so etwas koexistieren,
was auf den ersten einfachen Blick sich teilweise ja auch ein wenig zu widersprechen scheint?
Also zunächst ist es so, dass man in jedem Gebiet der Philosophie zunächst einmal methodologisch Atheist ist oder sein muss.
Also man nimmt nicht die Prämisse schon als Prämisse die Existenz Gottes mit in ein Argument mit hinein.
Das kann man sicher machen, wenn man Religionsphilosophie betreibt
und dann etwas bestimmtes betrachten will, unter der Annahme, dass es Gott gibt,
was ist dann eine moralisch gerechtfertigte Handlung.
So kann man das natürlich als Prämisse, die man aber kenntlich macht, mit reinnehmen.
Man kann nicht einfach voraussetzen für alle Argumente, die man in der Philosophie so verwendet, dass Gott existiert.
Das ist ein verbotener Schachzug im Werkzeugkasten der Philosophie.
Das ist geschummelt sozusagen.
Das ist geschummelt, ja.
Methodologisch ist man also Atheist.
Und jetzt kann man natürlich innerhalb der Religionsphilosophie versuchen,
die Existenz Gottes zu beweisen.
Also indem man beispielsweise versucht zu argumentieren, dass das Universum ja nicht aus Nichts entstanden sein kann.
Dass es eine erste Ursache haben muss.
Und diese erste Ursache könnte man dann mit Gott oder einer göttlichen Kraft identifizieren.
Wobei das ja auch überhaupt niemand behauptet, dass es aus dem Nichts erschaffen worden ist.
Die Wissenschaft ist ja eher auf dem Standort, wir wissen nicht, woraus es entstanden ist.
Wir gehen nur mal davon aus, dass es mal sehr sehr sehr klein war.
Aber ob es davor auch schon wieder groß war oder irgendwas ganz was anderes war.
Ist ja auch ein ontologisches Problem, sage ich mal, also so, was ist denn Nichts?
Okay, aber ich will nicht zu sehr von dieser Auseinandersetzung mit der Religion abweichen,
weil das natürlich ein Spannungsfeld ist.
Ja, was bei Fragen zur Religion natürlich mitschwingt ist, dass wir alle,
auch die rationalsten Philosophinnen und Philosophen ein Bedürfnis nach Spiritualität haben.
Die Frage, warum sind wir überhaupt hier, warum ist nicht etwa einfach nur nichts
und warum bin ich in dieses Leben geworfen?
Das ist eine Frage, die manchmal von Philosophen zur Seite geschoben wird
und als nicht beantwortbar oder als falsch gestellt markiert wird,
aber ich glaube, die wenigsten von uns können sich davon freisprechen, dass solche Fragen aufkommen.
Und wenn es der Moment ist, wo man einen lieben Menschen verliert, im Angesicht des Todes stellt man sich diese Fragen.
Und da versucht ja Religion, versuchen Religionen eben Antworten darauf zu geben.
Und deswegen ist das Anliegen ja ein durch und durch legitimes und für uns alle nachvollziehbares.
Wenn ich wieder auf die Metaphysik und Philosophie zurückkommen kann,
Metaphysik könnte man auch mal definieren als den Versuch,
das Leben und die Welt im Gesamten zu begreifen, zu ordnen, verstehbar zu machen.
Und idealerweise gelingt das kohärent, nämlich so, dass wir unser wissenschaftliches Wissen,
unser Alltagswissen und aber auch eventuell dieses Streben nach Spiritualität vereinbar machen.
So dass sich diese verschiedenen Bereiche eben nicht widersprechen.
So dass ich durchaus sagen kann, naturwissenschaftlich sieht es so und so aus,
und das tut meiner Lebenspraxis aber keine Abbruch.
Wenn man da eine Interpretation der Welt, der Wissenschaft, der Lebenswelt findet,
die es kohärent macht, dann ist das eine große Errungenschaft.
Als ich vorhin so ein bisschen nach der Zielgruppe gefragt habe,
was, glaube ich, ein bisschen, also von dem denXte-Projekt, was da so ein bisschen bei mir mitschwang war auch so,
dass ich das Gefühl habe, es gibt halt einen Teil der Gesellschaft, der ist in seiner Wissbegier aktiv
und beantwortete Fragen werden als eine Lücke angesehen, die man gerne füllen möchte.
Im Religionsbereich mag es ähnlich sein, nur dass dort die Bereitschaft ist,
mit sehr einfachen Antworten zu füllen, vielleicht etwas höher ist.
Man gibt sich mit etwas zufrieden, was irgendwie insgesamt gut klingt
und irgendwie was hermacht, sage ich mal, was einen aber auch auf eine gewisse Art und Weise fasziniert
oder eine gewisse Respekthaltung abverlangt, in der man sich auch wohlfühlt.
Bis hin zu einem Teil, und das haben wir ja in den letzten Jahren ja auch wieder verstärkt gesehen,
der eigentlich überhaupt gar keinen Wunsch zu haben scheint, wirkliche Erklärungen,
die in irgendeiner Form nachvollziehbar sind und die man so mit Logik sich irgendwie herleiten könnte,
für sich zu akzeptieren, weil es nicht ins Weltbild passt.
Finde ich an der Stelle auch einen schönen Begriff, Weltbild so, ich mache mir von der Welt ein Bild.
Projiziere quasi meine eigene Lebenssituation und wie ich sie gerne hätte
oder vielleicht auch die eigene Lebenssituation, wie ich sie eigentlich gar nicht so gerne habe,
aber die mich sozusagen bedrückt, schick das durch einen Spiegel und sage,
es ist alles anders und daran glaube ich jetzt und daraus beziehe ich eine gewisse Festigkeit.
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen ausgeholt, ich frage mich halt natürlich wie alle,
die auf dieses Fakenews-Syndrom und Verschwörungserzählungen und so weiter,
diese Bewegungen schauen so, was ist denn da eigentlich das, was zu fehlen scheint?
Dass man die Leute mit einem philosophischen Gesamtmodell und einem Wissensbegriff nicht mehr so richtig überzeugen kann,
nicht mehr ins Boot geholt bekommt?
Ist es zu weit weg, setzt es zu viel voraus, ist es zu kompliziert, übersteigt es die Fähigkeit zur intellektuellen Schlussfolgerung?
Was fehlt da und was lässt sich davon reparieren?
Ja, während ich das letztere nicht glaube, in vielen Fällen mangelt es glaube ich nicht an Verstand.
Der wäre wahrscheinlich da.
Aber ich möchte ganz klar sagen, dass das im Kern eher eine soziologische,
politisch, psychologische Frage ist, was führt dazu Menschen, dass sie sich in solchen Verschwörungstheorien versteigen,
auf Fakenews reinfallen?
Das weiß ich als Philosoph nicht zu beantworten, weil es eben eher einer soziologischen Studie bedarf,
als das darüber nachdenken im Lehnstuhl.
Da muss man sich eben genau die Bevölkerungsgruppen angucken und ihre Motivation ansehen.
Aber so Themen wie Fakenews sind ja im Rahmen vom denXte auch mal bewegt worden.
Schon, ja natürlich.
Da ist dann aber wie beim Wissensbegriff oder beim Naturgesetzesbegriff eben die Frage,
wie wollen wir das definieren?
Was ist also Fakenews im Gegensatz zu echten News?
Beispielsweise muss hinter Fakenews auch eine üble Absicht stecken?
Oder können Fakenews auch entstehen, dadurch das eine Google-Suchmaschine auf mein Profil schon abgestimmt ist
und mir dann Dinge auf meinen Browser spült, die ganz konzentriert auf mich sind?
Das heißt, ich befinde mich in der so viel beschworenen Bubble und bekomme anderes nicht mit.
Jetzt ist das noch nicht sofort Fakenews, aber könnte es sein, dass so ein Algorithmus das zufällig mir anspült?
Irgendetwas was entweder irrelevant oder irreführend ist.
Da wäre ja dann keine böse Absicht dahinter.
Also wann wird eine Falschmeldung zu einer Fakenews?
Zu einer Fakenews und ist es da relevant, dass eine böse Absicht dahintersteckt.
Das könnte man beispielsweise fragen, um eben News und Fakenews voneinander zu trennen.
Und solcherlei begriffliche Fragen, das ist wiederum die Aufgabe einer Begriffsanalyse und der Sprachphilosophie vielleicht in diesem Falle.
Also nicht etwa, wer fällt darauf typischerweise rein, sondern wie definieren wir es überhaupt?
Was ist das, Fakenews?
Okay, das deckt sich dann wieder mit der Betrachtung von vorhin, das ist wie Mathematik ein großer Werkzeugkasten ist für andere Disziplinen,
um überhaupt auch eine gemeinsame Sprache finden zu können.
Ja.
Also eine gemeinsame Wissenschaftssprache auch, also jetzt nicht mit, wir reden jetzt alle englisch,
sondern wir haben sozusagen dieselbe Vorstellung davon, was wir meinen, wenn wir sagen X.
Genau. Und manchmal, wie bei dem Begriff Fakenews, hat das dann Überlappung zur,
sagen wir, Politikwissenschaft, wo sich dann beide Gruppen darum bemühen können,
um eine vernünftige Definition davon.
Aber es gibt eben auch Angelegenheiten wie, wann liegt ein Kausalzusammenhang vor,
um den sich eben kaum andere Wissenschaften kümmern und das ist dann ein genuin philosophischer Themenbereich.
Aber es gibt durchaus die vielen Überlappungen zu anderen Wissenschaften.
Viele Wissenschaften sind aus der Philosophie entstanden, haben sich auch abgespalten,
von daher ist diese Zusammenarbeit weiterhin immer fruchtbar und beiden Disziplinen dann dienlich.
Interdisziplinäre Forschung spielt eine große Rolle in vielen Bereichen.
Das merke ich auch immer wieder hier bei den Gesprächen mit Forschergeist,
dass selten eigentlich noch, vor allen bei jüngeren, neueren Projekten, Initiativen allein die einzige Disziplin,
in der man jetzt selbst unterwegs ist, eine Rolle spielt, sondern man vernetzt sich sehr.
Inwiefern findet denn die Philosophie Unterschlupf in solchen Projekten?
Wer zieht die Philosophie für sich noch mit heran, um Forschungsprojekte vollständig zu machen?
Na wir haben eben schon über die Spezialisierung gesprochen.
Und da kann es in allen Wissenschaften sein, dass man eben aufgrund dieser Spezialisierung nicht nach rechts oder links schaut.
Aber das Thema, was wir eben behandelt haben, das Thema nach den Naturgesetzen,
da ist es so, dass beispielsweise die Philosophie unbedingt informiert sein muss von den physikalischen Theorien.
Also es nutzt ja nichts, wenn man behauptet, Naturgesetze müssen deterministisch sein.
Das wäre ja der totale Quatsch, weil wir spätestens seit der Quantenmechanik wissen,
dass es genuin indeterministische Gesetze gibt.
Das heißt, hier muss die Philosophie mindestens mal auf die Physik hören.
Von daher gibt es da eine große Überlappungen.
Es gibt auch Überschneidungen zur Linguistik.
Also nicht deterministisch, also im Sinne von nicht final bestimmbar, nicht eindeutig klar beschreibbar an einem bestimmten Punkt.
Ja, es sind Wahrscheinlichkeitsaussagen, und zwar nicht Wahrscheinlichkeitsaussagen derart,
wenn ich den Würfel jetzt hier werfe, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass eine sechs kommt, ein Sechstel.
Das wäre eine Wahrscheinlichkeit, da könnte man ja noch sagen,
naja, aber wenn du genau wüsstest, wo welche Luftmoleküle sind,
wie die Reibung auf dem Tisch ist, wie der Würfel gelagert ist,
dass das ein ganz fairer Würfel ist, wenn man das alles wüsste,
dann könnte man sich das ausrechnen, prinzipiell ausrechnen.
Dass der Würfel auf der Kante stehen bleibt.
Dass der auf der Kante stehen bleibt, im Zweifelsfall auf der Kante stehen bleibt.
Sondern die Quantenmechanik zeigt uns, dass es Vorgänge in der Natur gibt,
da gibt es nicht mehr zu wissen, sondern die enden mit der Wahrscheinlichkeitsaussage.
Man kann nicht näher ranzoomen oder nicht mehr Wissen aufnehmen, es endet dort.
Es gibt einfach nur die Wahrscheinlichkeitsaussage, zu 50 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit geht das Elektron durch den linken Spalt
und zu weiteren 50 Prozent durch den rechten, aber es gibt nichts weiter,
was man an Elektronen erforschen könnte, um dann rauszufinden, wo es hingeht.
Da endet einfach die Story.
Das heißt es ist genuin probabilistisch wahrscheinlich.
Und das hat die Quantenmechanik gezeigt, jedenfalls die allermeisten Interpretationen der Quantenmechanik sagen das.
Es gibt so ein paar Ausnahmen, die von Bohm beispielsweise,
die geht von versteckten Variablen aus.
Da weiß ich aber zu wenig, als dass wir da weiter sprechen könnten.
Jedenfalls ist die Standardmeinung die, dass wir auf genuin statistische Prozesse
oder genuin probabilistische Prozesse zurückgeworfen sind.
Wenn jetzt die Philosophie behaupten würde, naja aber Naturgesetze sind halt nur deterministisch
oder Kausalvorgänge sind immer nur notwendig, da kann nichts, dann wäre das ja schlicht falsch.
Also spielt auch die Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung in der Philosophie eine Rolle?
Ja, insofern als dass man mit an Bord nehmen muss, dass …
… die Dinge auch anders sein können.
Genau.
Okay, aber das war jetzt für mich so ein bisschen die falsche Richtung, weil das ist ja jetzt die Perspektive,
was muss die Philosophie von anderen Forschungsbereichen für sich selber mit annehmen.
Ich war, glaube ich, ein bisschen mehr auf der Suche nach der Nützlichkeit der Philosophie für die anderen Forschungsprojekte,
vielleicht suche ich so ein bisschen nach Beispielen, wo so eine interdisziplinäre Forschung die Philosophie explizit mit einbindet
oder ist das eher die Ausnahme?
Wir können uns das Ganze ja mal historisch angucken und merken da schnell,
dass beispielsweise Staatsformen, auch solche, die uns sehr lieb geworden sind, nämlich die Demokratie,
dass das zunächst auch philosophische Fragestellungen waren,
wie soll ein Staat eigentlich aufgebaut sein?
Und dadurch dass das aber so ein Common Sense ist, zumindest hoffentlich bei den meisten Bürgerinnen und Bürgern hier,
dass Demokratie sicher die beste Staatsform ist.
Oder die am wenigsten schlechte.
Wenn man so will.
Jedenfalls ist das so stark in unser Alltagswissen eingebunden, dass wir überhaupt vergessen, dass das zur Debatte stand
und eine philosophische Frage war, wie soll eigentlich ein Staat aussehen,
wie soll auch ein gerechter Staat aussehen?
Von daher informiert die Philosophie praktischerseits an dieser Stelle die Politik oder hat es getan.
Da sind wir auch wieder beim Verfassungsgericht bzw. überhaupt bei der Verfassung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und anderer Länder.
Genau.
Oder wir sind hier auch viel umgeben in diesem Studio von Computern
oder das was man mal Computer nannte, wie Tablets und Mobiltelefone und so weiter,
die basieren ja alle oder es ist jedenfalls enorm wichtig, dass da eine Logik entwickelt wurde.
Also Programmiersprachen, die letztlich dann auf Logiken aufbauen, auf and- und or-Verknüpfungen ganz basal am untersten fundamentalen Ende.
Und diese Logik wurde von einem Philosophen, von Gottlob Frege, entwickelt.
Und ohne diese Fregesche Logik könnte man sagen…
Kein iPhone.
Ja, ganz genau.
Ja, na gut, das historische Vermächtnis der Philosophie sei unbenommen.
Das ist sicherlich offensichtlich, auch wenn es sicherlich richtig ist, dass viele Leute das jetzt nicht unmittelbar damit in Verbindung bringen.
Die Frage ist, was sind sozusagen die Herausforderungen der Philosophie für die Zukunft?
Also was sind sozusagen die Gestaltungsrahmen, in denen man jetzt philosophische Betrachtungen und Analytiker mit einbringen muss,
die uns in der Zukunft weiterhin wichtige Dienstleistungen besorgen.
Also klar, ich denke auch, dass wir im Bereich von Gesellschaftslogik oder Gesellschaftsformen und Staatsformen
auch noch nicht unbedingt am Ende angekommen sind.
Letzten Endes muss man sich wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Gedanken machen über so one World, wie könnte es funktionieren.
So richtig super weit sind wir da ja jetzt noch nicht gekommen.
Also zeichnet sich zumindest jetzt nicht ab, dass das Thema in den nächsten 30 Jahren erledigt ist.
Was steht sozusagen an am Horizont für diese Philosophie?
Selbstfahrende Autos, da haben wir eben schon drüber gesprochen.
Und dahinter steckt natürlich die künstliche Intelligenz.
Das ist ein großes Thema, mit dem sich Philosophinnen und Philosophen auch beschäftigen.
Und zwar auf verschiedene Weise, die praktische wie die theoretische Philosophie involvierend.
Die praktische Philosophie dafür haben wir eben schon ein Beispiel genannt,
künstliche Intelligenzen müssen Regeln, Handlungsanweisungen bekommen.
Regeln, wie sie denn in moralisch aufgeladenen Situationen zu reagieren haben.
Das ist die eine Seite, die die praktische Philosophie betrachtet.
Die theoretische Philosophie kann hier mehrere Fragen stellen.
Zum Beispiel die, ist es so, dass diese Systeme oder ab wann würden wir sagen,
dass diese Systeme ihr eigenes Bewusstsein entwickeln, was muss dafür der Fall sein,
dass wir denen das zusprechen können?
Unser Tablet und Mobiltelefon hat das sicher noch nicht, auch wenn wir machmal mit den Dingern fast so umgehen,
als wären es Gesprächspartner, aber denen würde man nicht zuschreiben, dass sie ein Selbstbild beispielsweise von sich haben.
Aber da ist die Frage, ist das möglich oder wann würden wir von einem solchen Gerät das denn sagen wollen, dass es so ist?
Ein genuin philosophische Frage.
Ein weiteres Thema ist, dass diese künstlichen Intelligenzen ja auch jetzt schon in der Wissenschaft eingesetzt werden.
Es gibt Programme, die Moleküle viel besser erkennen können als Menschen das können.
Oder Programme, die auch vorhersagen in einer bestimmten Wissenschaft viel schneller treffen können
und korrekter, verlässlicher treffen können als wir das können.
Aber es ist ja oft nicht wirklich eine Intelligenz, die hier wirkt, sondern es ist ja eigentlich nur analysierte Vergangenheit,
die hier zum Tragen kommt.
Ja.
Also das maschinelle Lernen, was ja gemeinhin als künstliche Intelligenz hochgejazzt wird,
ist ja eigentlich eher der Blick in die Vergangenheit, aus dem sich in eingeschränktem Maße,
nämlich nur durch das wie es immer war, eine Aussage für die Zukunft treffen.
Machen Sie das denn anders, das machen wir Menschen ja auch so.
Naja.
Wo ist da der Unterschied?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich würde sagen, … also ich mag eigentlich dieses Beispiel mit diesen selbstfahrenden Autos nicht,
weil ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht unbedingt davon ausgehe, dass das so ein erstrebenswerter Zustand ist,
allein schon wegen des Trolley-Problems, aber auch generell, /unverständlich/
Ich meine, selbstfahrende Autos heißen für mich eigentlich Züge.
Aber das führt jetzt ein bisschen zu weit.
Ich will mich jetzt nicht zu hoch einschätzen, aber die Intelligenz oder der Begriff Intelligenz damit verbinde ich eben auch eine Fähigkeit,
aus so einem spontanen intuitiven Moment heraus eine Entscheidung fällen zu können,
die eben dann auch sich entkoppelt von so einem vorstrukturierten Wissen,
was ja so maschinelles Lernen ist.
Nein, nein, also es gibt maschinelles Lernen, was auf dem besten Wege ist, genau das zu tun.
Diese neuesten Maschinen sind ja nicht so, dass man denen nur etwas einprogrammiert
oder dass die nur eine vorgegebene Reihe lernen und diese Reihe dann fortsetzen können,
sondern die sind dergestalt, dass sie ihre eigenen Begrifflichkeiten beispielsweise entwickeln,
um damit dann vorhersagen zu treffen, also die sind hochkreativ in dem was sie tun.
Ich bin kein Experte, deswegen kann ich das nicht tiefer erklären.
Aber es ist so, dass die manchmal deswegen so viel bessere Vorhersagen treffen als Menschen das tun,
weil die die Welt andres einteilen und anders begrifflich in Begriffe eben einteilen.
Und da sind wir an einem interessanten philosophischen Punkt,
dann haben wir es mit Systemen zu tun, die uns überlegen sind in ihren Vorhersagen,
die wir aber nicht verstehen, weil sie anders denken, eine andere Sprache sprechen.
Das heißt, wir haben manchmal keine Überprüfungsmechanismen.
Wenn so ein System eine Vorhersage trifft, im schlimmsten Fall so was wie,
übermorgen gibt es den totalen Börsencrash, jetzt nicht mehr verkaufen oder so etwas
oder jetzt unbedingt das und das millionenfach verkaufen.
Wenn das System das rät, dann können wir es nicht nachvollziehen, warum das System das getan hat.
Diese Rechtfertigung, von der eben die Rede war, menschliches Wissen ist ungefähr wahre gerechtfertigte Meinung,
aber dieses Wissen oder jedenfalls korrekte Vorhersagen, die diese Systeme treffen,
da kennen wir die Rechtfertigung nicht, wir können die nicht nachvollziehen,
weil die anders begrifflich unterwegs sind, aber sie waren in der Vergangenheit wahnsinnig verlässlich.
Was machen wir jetzt in so einer Situation?
Verlassen wir uns dann darauf oder nicht?
Wir kommen an die Rechtfertigung nicht ran.
Im zwischenmenschlichen Umgang ist es gut, nach Rechtfertigungen zu fragen,
hier können wir es plötzlich nicht.
Und da stehen wir vor dem nächsten philosophischen Problem.
Als welche Art kognitiven Agenten betrachten wir denn diese künstlichen Intelligenzen?
Nehmen Sie ein anderes Wort, wenn Ihnen das Wort Intelligenz nicht gefällt.
Diese Systeme, System ist vielleicht ein neutralerer Begriff, wie gehen wir damit um?
Also ich bin dann glücklich, wenn diese Systeme mit ihrer angeblichen Intelligenz mir das ganze auch philosophisch herleiten können,
was sie jetzt gerade für eine Entscheidung gefällt haben.
Ja.
Ansonsten würde ich im Zweifelsfall derzeit immer noch auf Warren Buffett setzen,
der einfach mit einer Intuition an die Sache rangeht, was den Erfolg an der Böse betrifft
und da bisher eigentlich auch noch alle Maschinen geschlagen hat.
Ja, aber das ist…
Das ist ein offenes Rennen.
Ich meine, ja das ist ein offenes Rennen bzw. ist die Frage ja auch bei ihm die,
wie macht er das denn eigentlich, wo holt er die Intuition her?
Und das macht er ja nicht, indem er in eine Kristallkugel guckt oder einen Wahrsager befragt.
Sondern diese Intuition die wird ja aus seinem System erzeugt.
Sein Hirn hat einen Grundstock von Erfahrungen und macht mit diesen Erfahrungen etwas, bietet ihm diese Intuition an.
Und dieses „sein Gehirn“ hat auch aufgrund von vergangenen Erfahrungen lernen müssen,
um dann aus dem Erlernten eben die Intuition zu entwickeln.
Die kommt ja nicht vom Himmel, die kommt auch nicht aus der Kristallkugel,
sondern die kommt auch aus vergangen erlerntem.
Das heißt, ob wir da den jetzt entwickelten Maschinen so unähnlich sind,
es muss jedenfalls auch auf vergangener Erfahrung beruhen,
denn ich habe den methodologischen Atheismus eben erwähnt,
genau so methodologisch ist das Kristallkugellesen einfach nicht funktioniert.
Oder dass diese Intuition nicht einfach eine Eingebung aus dem Himmel ist,
sondern das Hirn muss das schon irgendwie erzeugt haben.
Also in dem Spiel, was wir hier spielen, würde ich halt sagen,
die Lernprozesse, die Warren Buffett bei sich zulässt, das ist sozusagen die Auswahl der richtigen Erfahrungen,
das ist die Intelligenz, um sich dann trainieren zu können.
Während es halt bei Maschinen klappen kann, wenn die Auswahl des richtigen Trainingsmodells,
also woraus lerne ich jetzt eigentlich, wenn das richtig war.
Und auch das ist dann halt wieder eine Intelligenz, die bisher noch von Menschen geleistet wird.
Wahrscheinlich ist der Untergang nah, in dem Moment, wo die Maschinen sich dann selber das richtige aussuchen können,
mit dem sie sich jetzt trainieren, weil dann ist alles vorbei.
Ja, das ist ja sehr pessimistisch.
/lacht/ Naja das sind halt unsere apokalyptischen …
SciFi-Movies.
Ja, aber bisher passiert es ja dann auch nicht.
Das ist ja dann auch wiederum ganz gut.
Ja.
Super, vielen Dank.
Das war eine schöne Reise in die philosophische Denkwelt
und auch in den Ansatz, wie man Philosophie der Öffentlichkeit schmackhaft und zugänglich machen kann.
Wunderbar.
Insofern vielen Dank hier auch für’s Zuhören bei Forschergeist.
Bald geht es wieder weiter, ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.